buenas tardes
javier núñez fran alicante bueno esta es
vuestra bien buenas tardes un placer de
estar aquí este mundo
este envío puedes hacer una introducción
explicada
a mis dientes perfecto en español
español español perfecto bueno pues yo
soy javier muñiz soy soy youtube y bueno
tengo un
un canal llamado escuela de memoria con
dos amigos josé maría ve a manuel pérez
y bueno pues en ese canal y en nuestra
web de escuela de memoria enseñamos
mnemotecnia técnicas de memorización
entonces bueno lo que hacemos es
explicar a la gente
como puede memorizar mucha información
de forma más divertida y más sencilla
utilizando técnicas de competición bueno
te voy a dejar un enlace a tu canal en
la descripción porque yo creo que este
puede ser muy interesante para mí
salientes que quieren aprender idiomas y
claro que la memorización y técnicas de
memorización tienen a ver con el
aprendizaje de idiomas que en tu
experiencia que son ejemplos o técnicos
de técnicos útiles sobre todo por
exactamente en el aprendizaje de idiomas
bien en el aprendizaje de idiomas es
cierto que no es igual que otros tipos
de aprendizaje que podemos hacer por
ejemplo nosotros lo que más trabajamos
es aprendizaje de temario pues para
estudiantes gente que tiene aprender
fórmulas matemáticas fechas muchos datos
pero sí que es cierto que en el
aprendizaje de idiomas nos puede ayudar
también la la mnemotecnia para que nos
puede servir pues nos puede servir para
varias cosas sobre todo cuando estamos
empezando por qué y esto tú lo sabes
bien steve cuando uno empieza a perder
un idioma lo que tenemos que hacer es
repetir mucho
y que implica repetir mucho repetir
mucho implica que tenemos que estar con
nuestros apuntes o con un diccionario
delante y repasando muchas veces
entonces tenemos hoy en día es más fácil
con los smartphones con internet es
mucho más fácil pero con la mnemotecnia
podemos memorizar palabras o memorizar
su pronunciación y poder repasar las
luego pues cuando estamos en por ejemplo
en el autobús o cuando estamos haciendo
la compra podemos rápidamente hacer esa
asociación y recordar la palabra para
repasar la no sería algo para hablar de
forma fluida pero sí nos ayudaría a
recordar para poder hacer un repaso más
continuo si es cierto que al principio
con un nuevo idioma es muy difícil
porque todo es nuevo
por ejemplo cuando yo he aprendido los
caracteres por el chino
yo utilizaba un sistema de space respect
y sin repetición como dice en español
repetición espaciada correcto espaciada
para aprender ese es un sistema propio
que yo he desarrollado pero al principio
si yo creo que puede ayudar al y tenemos
esas ministro les con mucha repetición
pero yo creo que efectivo efectivamente
al principio tenemos que tratar de
contenidos menos interesantes muchas
palabras desconocidos desconocidas
entonces pero puedes explicar y más
concretamente no como éste funciona
perfecto sí bueno la clave sería las
técnicas de memorización se basan
siempre en la memoria visual valen en
recordar escenas porque porque nosotros
recordamos muy bien cuando somos
pequeños nos enseñan con cuentos porque
recordamos muy bien las historias y las
conclusiones a los que llegan los
cuentos
igual que las películas recordamos muy
bien las escenas y las escenas nos
llevan a recordar incluso diálogos
entonces lo que hacemos es recordar una
escena que no sea sobre todo muy
espectacular o muy rara por ejemplo
siempre decimos que las escenas tiene
que ser muy exageradas tienen que haber
por ejemplo animales gigantes o
explosiones algo que llame mucho la
atención que capturen nuestra
imaginación
por ejemplo en español alguna cosa que
hacemos pues si queremos memorizar por
ejemplo la palabra piel o almohada en
castellano y digo para la memorización
de castellano inglés en este caso pues
pillow
la asociamos a una palabra que se
pronuncie de forma similar entonces por
ejemplo puede ser piloto para el auto un
piloto de avión
entonces se puede imaginar nosotros
haríamos imagina una escena con un
piloto con su gorra y que llega al avión
está cansado pero dentro de la cabina y
un montón de almohadas está yendo todo
de almohadas son una escena muy rara muy
no recuerdo el título en el título
original aquí en españa es aterriza como
puedas
no me acuerdo del título pero bueno
sería eso pues imagina el piloto que
llega muy cansado y se tira sobre las
almohadas entonces cuando quiera
recordar almohadas recuerdas dónde qué
escena me acuerdo yo te viene
automáticamente la esa imagen y sabes
que es el piloto y por piloto ya puedes
sacar el resto de la palabra sí
bueno este cuesta mucho trabajo como
cuántas palabras puedes aprender con
esas técnicas pues que hay un límite
porque reprobó para mí aprender un
idioma querer ir a aprender diez mil
palabras veinte mil palabras pues al
final yo
como digo es en este caso este método no
es no salgo este es específicamente
optimizado para idiomas es un recurso
adicional pero sí que hay una cosa que
es cierta y es que se puede memorizar
mucha más información así de la que la
gente cree por un motivo muy sencillo y
esto es un ejemplo que pongo siempre de
escribir una escena o narrar una escena
si la escribes en un libro cuesta mucho
nosotros vemos vamos al cine y vemos una
escena del señor de los anillos el
hobbit y rápidamente nos quedamos con
los detalles del paisaje en un momento
si leemos a tolkien vemos esa
descripción extensísima para hacernos
esa imagen mental necesitamos una
descripción muy larga pero sin embargo
el cerebro almacena de forma bastante
eficiente las imágenes tenemos un amigo
en escuela de la memoria que de hecho
lleva memorizados memoria está
especializado en memorizar decimales de
del número pi
lleva creo que está cerca de los 90.000
con luchas dando este sistema que es
alucinante es un amigo nuestro lleva
muchos años le sucede como a ti lleva
muchos años le encanta su hobby y lo
hace todo con imágenes o sea es y nos
demuestra es un ejemplo muy claro de qué
de que se puede no es algo evidentemente
es algo que lleva requiere su tiempo y
requiere más tiempo adicional pero sobre
todo este tipo de sistemas nos pueden
ayudar para dos cosas una para recordar
esas palabras que de otra forma nos
cuesta mucho porque palabras que porque
sean más largas más difíciles nos cuesta
más memorizar este método nos puede
servir a nosotros por ejemplo no lo
recomendamos para para recordar todas
las palabras sino para recordar aquellas
que es como pegarnos contra un muro que
intentamos recordarla y porque sea muy
larga muy complicada no se nos queda
entonces recurrimos a este tipo de
estrategia
como bueno ahora que estoy aprendiendo
un idioma como tengo que pensar a
escenas para cada palabra o hay quienes
por ejemplo por el inglés por los
españoles tienes una lista de escenas
que pueden ser utilizadas utilizadas
como cómo funciona como tú haces para
ayudar a la gente a utilizar esas
mnemotécnicas en el aprendizaje de
idiomas se puede hacer ahí hay varias
estrategias que se pueden utilizar como
digo lo bueno de
sobre todo cuando las palabras no son
muy abstractas cuando estamos hablando
de objetos hablar de un bolígrafo o de
una cámara lo bueno es que no hace falta
que esas escenas estén agrupadas por
ejemplo existe otra otra técnica llamada
el palacio de memoria memory para las
que si se puede utilizar para agrupar
dentro de un lugar físico en una
habitación en una ciudad que hayas
visitado y pones en un parque de esa
ciudad donde se imagina las distintas
escenas esto sería sobre todo para
vocabulario a lo mejor técnico que
necesites recordar ciertas palabras y
que estén agrupadas pero para objetos lo
bueno es que el recordar la propia
imagen del objeto o visualizarlo
que rápidamente el cerebro va a enlazar
con la escena si yo quiero aprender cómo
se dice
por ejemplo bolígrafo es fácil si yo me
imagino escribiendo en un examen con un
bolígrafo a lo mejor que no pinta y que
me frustro porque no pinta pues cuando
me acuerde bolígrafo rápidamente no
prevenir la escena de que estaba
describiendo entonces es muy es más
bastante automático relativamente al
llegar hasta ahí no sería tan fluido
como para conversar pero sí para pensar
unos segundos y que nos viniesen la
palabra
para mí siempre me parece que
el aprendizaje de cosas
semejantes parecidos parecidas es más
difícil por ejemplo de los colores si
tengo que aprender los colores
[Música]
y al mismo tiempo es muy difícil pero si
tengo por ejemplo la hierba verde o una
u otra asociación con el color y con una
otra cosa es más fácil si la misma cosa
con la ropa con los parientes
y todo eso pero por algunas palabras
esas palabras
clave palabras clave a mí me interesa la
historia de la política entonces hay
palabras como
reunión institución proposición
es un poco difícil acordarse y ese sería
palabras palabras claves para mí porque
parece muchas veces en la conversación
cada vez lo olvido pero si había alguna
manera para aprender esas digamos en la
política 100 palabras
pero muchas veces no
valdrá la pena de investir este esfuerzo
en un sistema de memorización claro eso
es precisamente a lo que me refería y
para estas palabras precisamente ha sido
un buen ejemplo te has puesto con los
colores porque con la memorización es
uno de los primeros errores que se
cometen el intentar memorizar con ideas
muy abstractas y memorizar ideas muy muy
abstractas es complicado el cerebro
reconoce muy bien no recuerda muy bien
cosas que puede ver y tocar entonces es
eso sí para el verde nos acordamos de la
hierba o de una tortuga por ejemplo es
fácil o para el rojo pues un tomate una
manzana el fuego es mucho más sencillo
y para este tipo de conceptos clave que
comentaba pues lo que se hace es algo
similar cuando nuestros alumnos por
ejemplo tenemos alumnos que tienen que
aprender de leyes
memorizar leyes y el lenguaje legal es
complicadísimo y muy abstracto entonces
lo que intentamos siempre es que las
palabras
se puedan descomponer en otras más
sencillas o buscar alguna imagen que de
alguna forma recuerde
precisamente sea eso pues por ejemplo
para una reunión pues no solo ver a
gente reunida sino aparte añadir alguna
alguna palabra que te recuerde a cómo
empieza
vale reunión por re podría ser
en español una res que serían las vacas
por estimación a una reunión de vacas
para que sepas vale están juntos pero
que es es una reunión es una fiesta que
es es muy simplificado vale sería más
desarrollado pero la idea sería esa algo
que que no haya lugar que no nos dé
lugar a duda
bueno todo eso es muy interesante
yo
sugiero a mis clientes de visitar a tu
canal porque pueden mejorar su nivel de
español
cualquiera muchos que estudian
castellano
y también descubrir técnicas que pueden
ayudar en la y la memorización y también
en mejorar su nivel de español sí como
bueno como como decíamos aparte antes es
siempre aprender es divertido da igual
que se idiomas que sea yo soy una
persona a la que a mí me encanta
personalmente aprender y siempre
disfruto descubriendo algo nuevo
entonces pues siempre es divertido el
desarrollar una nueva habilidad sea un
idioma sea memorizar o sea como digo
coser pero como tienes
bueno muchas muchas gracias por la
entrevista y vamos a continuar esta
conversación
[Música]